I'd love to go deeper would you be
willing to let me analyze you a bit more
oh listen if you're willing to go in
here I'm ready I mean your legs are
gonna be really high and the seat it's a
very high seat in the ya know it fall
asleep in therapy if this is what it
looked like actually it'd be like open
up and I'd be like you sure this is a
trip you want to take yes yes let's do
it okay so when was the last time you
really cried I'm crying inside right now
oh so you're uncomfortable around people
okay okay okay what's the one thing in
life you're still trying to find my hair
[Laughter]
I swear you can borrow mine I would I
went to bed one night it was there and I
woke up the next morning you're gone
I've been bald since I was 12
that's all right it's tough I like it
you know one time that 78% of men would
amputate a body part rather than be bald
I know when they wouldn't to be I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this